now that you've made your sixth movie
and this is the first one without Will
Ferrell is he really upset that you
didn't put him in this movie he's livid
yeah he keeps walking by my office I
have a glass front to my office and just
staring me down back and forth Adam
McKay welcome to fandango frontrunners
thank you very happy to have you here
pleasure to be here here's what I love
about you in the big short I feel like
this movie you've really flipped the
script on your perception in the movie
business after directing five crazy will
ferrell comedies now you're a double
Oscar nominee for Best Director and Best
Adapted Screenplay did you think this
movie could be a game-changer for you
you know what's so funny like you
whenever you make a movie you mainly
just focus on making the movie so I
wasn't till about halfway through the
movie when my Texas script supervisor
turned to me and said you know Adam you
may win an Academy Award for this and I
was like whoa um but otherwise no I
never thought of it in those terms I
just love the story I feel like the
great thing about this film when people
are done seeing it they're really
informed and they're really infuriated
at the same time but they also are
laughing do you always feel like humor
and education can go hand in hand or is
it tough to put those two together so I
mean it's one of the advantages of doing
a movie about real life is that you
don't really adhere to a genre it can
kind of be whatever it needs to be and
that excited me a lot about this movie
you're a former head writer at Saturday
Night Live you're one of the founders of
funny or die where does the comedy gene
come from in you haha that no one has
asked me that uh I would say there's no
better mix for comedy than repressed
irish-catholic with an artistic mother
and then I had a dad who loved comedy
who had a great laugh so somewhere
between those three things a little bit
of dysfunction you always need that okay
I also think I grew up in the 80s to it
was like when comedy was really blowing
up it was Letterman the simpsons were
coming online it was a great time to
grow
yeah is there one person in your life
who's most inspired you to become a risk
taker in your career it's a great
question you know I think I grew up
watching movies so much that like I just
inhaled movies I always have my entire
life and I think just through the years
I've noticed that the movies that really
affect me are the ones that take big
bold leaps I mean that having been said
there was a teacher i had in chicago
named Del Close who if you're in the
improv or comedy world you know who he
is he trained like you know Gilda Radner
Chris Farley mike myers all these
legendary people and his approach was
always play at the top of your
intelligence always take risks always go
for the third thought so for years I
worked with him in Chicago and we had a
comedy group called the upright citizens
brigade that came out of that and yeah
everything he preached was go for it
that we don't need to see people just
doing sort of work to fit in we want to
see something unusual so I would credit
him in a big way of all of the movies
that you could have taken on obviously
this topic and this book by Michael
Lewis spoke to you very personally what
was it about it that made you think I
have to do this one you know I think the
financial collapse affected everyone
like I had a very close family member
who lost their home at a lot of friends
who lost their jobs and yet I came out
of it not entirely knowing what had
happened so I think that was it the idea
that you could make an entertaining film
where you would be on the edge of your
seat yet also you know have your eyes
open to this major event that I think a
lot of us didn't totally get let's watch
a sequence from this movie where Ryan
Gosling's characters trying to explain
to a bunch of other traders what a
clatter I collateralized I can say this
what a collateralized debt obligation is
took me a couple times and he ends up
telling us the audience exactly what it
is so let her take a look yeah a big
short we just repackage it with a bunch
of other [ __ ] that didn't sell and put
it into a CEO a CDO yes a CDO what is
that this is where we take a bunch of
bees double bees and triple B's that
haven't sold and we put them in a pile
when the pile gets large enough the
whole thing is suddenly considered
diversified
ified and then the [ __ ] at the rating
agency give it a 92 93 percent triple-a
rating no questions asked say that again
okay so right now the whole audience
collective head hurts yeah right one of
the fun things was that you could
actually get really complicated and I
wanted the audience to be afraid that
they were about to get lost right uh and
we did it every time these explanations
would come on I would make sure the
technical language got very technical
and then right at that point you get to
pop in with what you're about to see
collateralized debt obligation it's
important to understand because it's
what allowed a housing crisis to become
a nationwide economic disaster here's
world-famous chef Anthony Bourdain to
explain okay I'm a chef on a Sunday
afternoon setting your menu the big
restaurant I ordered my fish on Friday
which is the mortgage bond that Michael
very shortage but some of the fresh fish
doesn't sell I don't know why maybe it
just came out how it has the
intelligence the dolphin so what am I
gonna do throw all this unsold fish
which is the triple B level of the bond
in the garbage and take the loss no way
being the crafty and morally onerous
chef that I am whatever crappy levels of
the bond I don't sell I throw into a
seafood stew see it's not old fish it's
a whole new thing the best part is
they're eating three-day-old halibut
that
I love that if Anthony Bourdain I had
read his book his great great book
kitchen confidential and he had
described don't ever order the seafood
stew that it's where they put all the
junk they can't sell so when I was
reading this sequence I thought of that
it was like oh my god that's a perfect
metaphor and this serves two functions
now I understand a CDO and I understand
I should never order seafood stew again
exactly well I congratulate you on and
it certainly educated me and infuriated
me so well done I love it Adam McKay
great to see you if you have not seen
the big short be sure to get your
tickets on fandango and check it out you
will love it thanks so much for watching
fandango frontrunners
you
you
you